resuelve para x y tenemos la desigualdad
compuesta menos 16 menor o igual que 3 x
5 que a su vez es menor o igual que 20
entonces esencialmente lo podemos
resolver como ya lo hemos hecho de más
aún hay dos formas de hacerlo y que de
hecho voy a hacerlas ok la primera de
ellas es resolverlo de forma simultánea
es decir voy a tomarme completita esta
desigualdad menos 16 menor o igual que 3
x más 5 menor o igual que 20 e ir
haciendo operaciones y resolverla todo
de un solo paso o bien tomarlas por
separado es decir tengo yo la de menos
16 menor o igual que 3 x 5 y
se debe cumplir también que 3 x 5 es
menor o igual que 20 si los si los hago
de forma separada lo único que tengo que
garantizar es que ambas tienen que ser
ciertas así que voy a hacer estos dos y
de hecho los voy a ir haciendo a la par
para que nos demos cuenta cómo es que es
exactamente igual así que por ejemplo si
empezamos del lado izquierdo con esta
desigualdad lo que podemos hacer es lo
que tenemos que hacer es esencialmente
también despejar la x muy bien así que
voy a restar 5 d en todos lados restó 5
aquí restó 5 acá restó 5 aquí y qué es
lo que nos queda menos 16 menos 5 son
menos 21 que es menor o igual que 3 x
más 5 menos 5 pues justamente por eso
restamos 5 para que se cancelen y me
queda 3x que es menor o igual que 20
menos 5 que son 15
restar 5 en todos lados es equivalente a
restar aquí cinco aquí también restar 5
restar 5 y restar 5 si lo ves entonces
tenemos menos 16 menos 5 son menos 21
que es menor o igual que 13 x y se debe
cumplir que 3 x 5 menos 5 pues son 3 x
sea menor o igual que 20 menos 5 que son
15 así que si ves estas dos son
exactamente equivalentes y ahora lo que
voy a hacer es dividir todo entre 3
dividir todo entre 3 que sé que si
dividimos todo entre 3 de este lado es
también lo mismo que si dividimos todo
entre 3 en cada una de estas
desigualdades y fíjate que no tenemos
que cambiar el signo de la desigualdad
porque estamos dividiendo entre un
número positivo muy bien entonces no se
cambia que es lo que me queda menos 21
entre 3 son menos 7 es menor o igual que
3 entre 13 son 1 así que me queda x
menor o igual que 15 entre 3 que son 5
por otro lado tenemos menos 21 entre 3
son
menos 7 menor o igual que x y se debe
cumplir que 3x entre 3 que es x es menor
o igual que 5 entonces ya tenemos
nuestra solución expresado de estas dos
formas que de hecho es exactamente la
misma muy bien como como lo pondríamos
en la recta numérica ahí tenemos nuestra
recta numérica aquí anda por ejemplo el
0 quizás por aquí anda el 5 entonces
sacando el -7 entonces todo nuestro
conjunto solución serán aquellos que
están entre menos 7 y 5 y si los
incluimos ok estamos entre menos 7 pero
no pasamos del 5 que entonces todo esto
es nuestro conjunto solución ok entonces
vamos a ver por ejemplo algunos casos
para que estemos cómodos y veamos que si
tenemos al menos unos ejemplos en donde
la desigualdad o nuestro conjunto de
solución es válido por ejemplo qué tal
si nos tomamos el 0 si sustituimos aquí
en cero tenemos tres por cero es cero
5 nos queda 5 que claramente si es mayor
o igual que menos 16 verdad y también es
cierto que es menor o igual que 20 muy
bien qué pasa por ejemplo si nos tomamos
el 5 exactamente tenemos 3 por 5 son 15
más cinco son 20 que otra vez 20 es
mayor o igual que menos 20 y 20 es menor
o igual a 20 de hecho son iguales por
eso pueden ser menor o iguales sé que
suena un poco complicado pero pero
también es cierto que pasa si nos
tomamos el menos 73 x menos 7 son menos
21 más 5 son menos 16 que es igual a
menos 16 y aquí está incluido la
posibilidad de que sean iguales y menos
16 claramente es menor o igual que 20
entonces esos tres puntitos y fueron
cierto y podrías intentar otros valores
que incluso puedes salirte del conjunto
solución por ejemplo puedes tomar puedes
tomarte 10 no por ejemplo 3 por 10 son
30 más 5 son 35 que si es cierto que es
mayor o igual que menos 16 lo que no es
cierto es que 35 sea menor o igual
20 es de hecho más grande entonces por
eso es que 10 no es parte de nuestro
conjunto solución